monsieur le sénateur l'eau vous avez
continué effectivement à m'interroger
sur la communauté politique européenne
et notamment sa taille je voudrais vous
rassurer merci nous n'avons pas
l'idée est pas de prendre des décisions
à 44 tout le temps l'idée c'est
effectivement de favoriser le dialogue
et les projets d'intérêt commun mais ça
peut être ambilatéral entre bilatérale
ou en pluridien latéral mais qu'ensemble
nous trouvions des chemins pour ancrer
tous ces pays
à l'Union européenne et son état de
droit vous avez émotionné mais ça a été
très important de que cet espace puisse
aussi permettre un dialogue entre la
Turquie et la Grèce ou entre la Turquie
et Chypre de la même façon qu'il y a eu
un dialogue entre l'Arménie et
l'Azerbaïdjan qui comme vous le savez a
conduit à la signature d'un accord qui
permet l'envoi d'une mission européenne
pour observer et rapporter au Comité des
frontières ce qui est en train de va
passer entre l'Arménie et laserbaïdjan
en ce qui concerne le financement vous
avez raison s'il faut des projets
concrets nous aurons besoin de
financement tout n'est pas arrêté il y a
plusieurs choses qui sont à l'étude
d'abord il peut y avoir une contribution
des organisations internationales comme
c'est le cas dans le cadre du G7 ou du
G20 il peut effectivement pourra aussi
s'appuyer sur des programmes existants
pour ne pas dupliquer et pour ne pas
manquer des choses et vous pouvez penser
aux partenariats oriental par exemple ou
à d'autres projets qui existent
aujourd'hui
vous m'avez ensuite interrogé sur
l'Europe de la défense d'abord ça fait
longtemps que je ne l'ai pas rappelé
mais dans les avancées de la présidence
française de l'Union européenne et il y
a effectivement un cadre cohérent et
ambition d'action de l'Union européenne
avec la boussole stratégique qui comme
vous le savez est le premier livre blanc
européen en matière
de sécurité je crois que c'est très
important parce que ça va définir à la
fois ce que nous pouvons faire sur le
moyen terme mais aussi donner des
orientations qui effectivement vont
avoir des effets sur le court terme sur
le court terme l'Europe est parvenue à
mobiliser les 2,5 milliards d'euros que
nous voulons augmenter à 3 milliards
comme je disais pour la livraison
d'armes
à l'Ukraine mais avec cette boussole et
d'autres et les autres actions de
l'Union européenne nous allons aussi
nous allons aussi permettre d'encourager
les investissements de défense et de
rationaliser les différents engagements
qui sont pris séparément par les
nombreux États membres une question que
m'a également posé je crois monsieur
sénateur gâteau lin et Monsieur
dessinateur guerriot
vraiment il y a une volonté de fournir
de l'aide et de la formation des
personnes de permettre des augmentations
de capacité des achats de munitions et
pour l'ensemble des pays de l'Union
européenne puisque
nous avons donné mais beaucoup de petits
pays ont aussi beaucoup donné à
l'Ukraine et donc l'idée c'est
effectivement de reconstituer des
capacités dans le court terme pour
continuer de soutenir l'Ukraine mais
aussi de se permettre à moyen terme
d'être plus efficace plus rapide et
d'avoir des instruments différents et
enfin
et je crois que c'est le souci tout le
monde et je voudrais juste le rappeler
ce n'est pas de la concurrence à l'OTAN
c'est une articulation avec le temps et
quand on travaillera
quand nous travaillons tous les deux en
bon articulation les deux institutions
je crois que nous sommes beaucoup plus
forts et beaucoup plus efficace
[Musique]